we're closin anybody have anything they
want to say I ain't got nothing to say
but dey do
I'm not much for giving inspirational
addresses let me tell you what I see you
got two more quarters and that's it
you're bigger faster stronger for
experience in this lifetime you don't
have to prove nothing to nobody except
yourself as you like a time I think I'm
a good fighter you gotta play tough off
those boards cuz if you're willing to go
through all the battling you got to go
through to get to where you want to get
who's got the right to stop you you
believe in yourselves or you believe in
your teammates you won't matter what
anyone else thinks
believe in the bowl I want you to treat
these like they're your babies that's
what I demand and that's what you're
gonna do inches we need are everywhere
around us what do you say I'm not crazy
I'm just thirst because it's not what
you do goddamn it how you doing oh
that's good we're gonna go nose-to-nose
with they don't know your art play the
game weight from your heart let's catch
up the biggest hearts I've ever seen you
have shown yourself just exactly who you
are in you let's win this and for all
the small schools never had a chance to
get here
yeah
ready - I'm ready for this my whole life
ever much defense defense defense this
is it is